(music)
I love science
Can you even imagine
Way back in the past when
We thought that storms were caused by petty
gods
Fightin' on top of a mountain?
And yeah I like a good story
But eventually it's gonna bore me
If it doesn't have that truth;
That incontrovertible, testable, repeatable
proof
I love science
And I love Charles Darwin
Cause I don't think it's bold to question
what you're told
If you're told that the world's a thousand
years old.
There's nothing here to argue against;
It's a process, not an ideology,
And I! Love! Science!
Sometimes people ask me,
Of all of the centuries,
Which I'd pick to live life in.
We'll, that's pretty easy
Right now. If you think objectively.
If you like hot running water,
And memory foam beds,
And TV shows and cell phones,
And not being dead
Then you love science,
And I love Carl Sagan
'Cause I think it's fly to look up at the
sky
And never, ever, ever stop wondering why
There's nothing here to argue against
It's a process, not an ideology,
I! Love! Science!
Wooly mammoth embryos
Vaccines for smallpox and polio
Your TV set, the internet
Your PS4, supersonic jets.
Exoplanets, galaxies,
DNA, germ theory, relativity,
Just take a sec to think about it
How sad life would be without it.
(sweet drum solo)
I love science
And I love Rosalind Franklin,
'Cause I want to die remembering why
The truth is more important than winning a
prize.
There's nothing here to argue against.
It's a process, not an ideology,
And I! Love! Science!
That is the first track on my new album Incongruent
with Hank Green and The Perfect Strangers.
Incongruent now has an official release date,
that date being May 7th. That's when it
will be available on iTunes. It will be shipping
out of the DFTBA warehouse a little bit before
that. All of those things shipping out, if
you pre-order the album, will be signed, and
you will also get an email with download links
so that you can download the MP3s 'cause
I know not everybody has a CD drive in their
computer anymore.
And we are going on tour after VidCon! Los
Angeles, San Francisco, Portland, Seattle,
Boise, Denver, Salt Lake City, possibly Eugene,
there's a link in the description if you
want to get tickets. For some peculiar reasons
it is extra important that we sell tickets
in Seattle, Salt Lake and Denver quickly.
Basically, the people booking the shows don't
believe us 'cause we've nerve toured before
and we need to show them that we can sell
tickets so they will be nice to us. And it
is not just me on this tour: it is also Rob
Scallon, it is also Andrew Huang, it is also
Driftless Pony Club, the band of Wheezy Waiter,
and it is also Harry and the Potters! It's
going to be a lot of fun! I'm excited about
it! All the shows are all ages, and all the
tickets are under $20, the prices vary. I
love science! John, I'll see you on Tuesday.